Americans use voice-activated digital
devices like myself the Amazon echo of
course with the personal Alexa assistant
but they also raise privacy concerns a
report this week on the tech news
website the information says Amazon is
considering giving transcripts of
Alexa's audio recordings to third-party
app developers in a statement to CBS
this morning amazon says we do not share
customer identifiable information to
third-party skills or apps without the
customers consent CBS News contributor
Nicholas Thompson is editor in chief of
Wired and is joining us with more so how
worried should we all be about what
Alexa knows about it and what they're
giving to advertisers well I think we
should be cautious these devices are
extremely useful they're effective
they're good but they also have a
totally different relationship with us
than our other devices and we say things
and they hear things that we really
wouldn't want everywhere and they're
potentially recording all the time so
there are huge potential privacy
violations that are gonna come down the
road are they recording when you're not
specifically talking to them
no they record when they hear the word
Alexa they have a little buffer before
it but that's the way they are right now
in the future they're probably gonna
record all the time once we get more
used to them right now Amazon is being
cautious because isn't what people would
be scared of them but the way privacy
and technology work is we just give it
up as time goes on so eventually they'll
record more and they'll sell it to more
places do we know are there a way to
delete recordings right now that are on
there yes there are two ways to do it
you can go into the Alexa app on your
phone and you can go in you can go to
settings and then you can go to history
and then they're all the individual
things you said and you can delete them
one by one or you can go into amazon.com
and you can go to the thing called
manage my content click on your Alexa
and you can delete all of it now the
problem with deleting all of it is that
Alexa gets better as it listens to you
so if you do that it will suddenly go
back to what it was when it came out of
the box so I went on that setting last
night you know what not gonna do it
mm-hmm so what do we say to those who
say you know what listen privacy is out
the door everything's about convenience
right now and forsaking privacy is worth
it given the convenience of devices like
Alexa
you say well then you should be happy I
mean those kind of people they're loving
life right now because we are constantly
giving a privacy and we are only going
to give up more privacy because we're
entering an era of artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence
depends on data data depends on
extracting as much as you can from all
of your customers so every big tech
company is trying to get as much data as
possible and to make it as accessible as
possible to all the different parts of
their company and all their different
products to get that data everywhere
they have to invade your privacy in all
kinds of ways so we have this constant
trade-off for convenience and for
innovation we give up our privacy I had
a question because in the statement that
Amazon provided us they say they don't
share this information without the
customer's consent when do we give
consent
oh it says we don't share identifiable
information without the customers
consent so it doesn't say Nora ordered a
pepperoni pizza on her Alexa it just
says a pepperoni pizza was ordered on an
Alexa or 700 people order pepperoni
pizzas so it's not they're not saying
exactly who did it
but as we all know from medical records
and lots of conversations in the past
smart people looking at non-identifiable
data can figure out who exactly said
what but how is this any different from
saying what Google already knows and
says Google knows and post all the time
what we're searching for it tells us
interesting trends about what people are
interested in what they want to do
because we're used to it because we now
understand that because we know when we
type and we type something into Google
we know that is going to follow us
around the web we know that it's going
to be sold and used in all kinds of ways
we aren't quite used to these Alexa's
yet we don't really understand that what
we're saying goes into a machine and
then gets sent to Amazon and then gets
chopped up and parsed and sent all these
other places we know that when we type
we don't know when we speak Nick
Thompson thank you very much thanks for
having me